bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de ski mag je
recharge les batteries et c'est parti ah
oui c'est vrai le gobelet en plastique
est un faux ami du tri en fait ce n'est
pas parce qu'il est en plastique il doit
être remis dans cette poubelle les
beaucoup trop léger pour être recyclés
mettez le plus tôt dans la poubelle
destinée aux ordures ménagères la
question du tri est vraiment très
importante d'ailleurs plus globalement
c'est toute la question de la gestion
des déchets qui est devenu primordial
dans nos sociétés modernes
imaginez une ville dans laquelle les
déchets ne serait ni collecter ni trier
ni recyclés ce serait tout bonnement
invivable alors à saint quentin en
yvelines depuis la réforme territoriale
depuis le 1er janvier 2016 c'est la
communauté d'agglomération qui se
chargent des tonnes de déchets produits
chaque année par les saint quentinois
comment ça marche c'est ce qu'on va voir
ensemble dans ce qu'imad c barbier
et
pas question de prendre la problématique
de la collecte et du tri des déchets à
la légère tout à l'heure je vous
demandais d'imaginer une ville jonchées
de déchets et bien sachez que ce
scénario catastrophe est déjà arrivés
très récemment en italie à naples plus
précisément où une série de mauvais
choix ont plongé la ville dans un chaos
sans nom
c'est pour éviter ce type de situation
épouvantable que les déchets doivent
être gérés de manière très stricte et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'y emploie
pour en parler
j'ai rencontré thierry hesse ligne
une organisation nouvelle est en train
de se mettre en place celle ci est très
complexe étant donné que vous avez douze
communes maintenant douze communes qui
avaient chacun leur mode de gestion des
déchets cette nouvelle organisation
travaille d'une manière intense pour
notamment à optimiser organiser les
nouveaux contrats à l'avenir la
l'homogénéisation qui est souhaitable
dans le domaine cette homogénéisation
passe dans un premier temps par un
transfert de compétences
ainsi les 12 communes de saint quentin
en yvelines ont transféré une
soixantaine de contrats de prestations à
la communauté d'agglomération en début
d'année l'ambition qui est la nôtre est
de réduire ce nombre de contrats et
surtout non pas les réduire pour les
réduire mais de les optimiser de faire
en sorte qu'on ait une homogénéisation
des prestations qui sont rendus à
l'ensemble des saint quentinois en
matière de déchets et faire en sorte
également que cette optimisation puisse
se concrétiser par des éléments
d'économie sensible de meilleurs
services donc des économies est très
important sans augmentation de la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
le territoire est désormais découpée en
quatre zones gérées par le service
déchets de la communauté d'agglomération
lui même composé de trois pôles
à commencer par le pôle pré collecte et
collecte c'est les apports volontaires
ou le ramassage en porte à porte
la conteneurisation également est
importante dans ce
dans ce pour le la deuxième pôle
prévention et valorisation des déchets
c'est l'éducation c'est l'information
afin de valoriser cette richesse que
sont les déchets bien qu'un déchet non
produit est une immense richesse à
déchets produits en études quand même il
faut faire en sorte de transformer cette
richesse et de la valoriser et enfin
troisième et dernier paul déchetterie
les déchetteries qui elles sont un pôle
de services qui représente un pôle de
services et qui apporte à la population
et qui apportera à certaines communes
qui n'ont pas encore des services
supplémentaires
pour comprendre l'importance que revêt
la question des déchets voici quelques
chiffres
plus de 250 kg c'est la quantité
d'ordures ménagères par an et par
habitant des saint quentinois
elle serait partie de cette manière en
tête coignières suivi de trappes plaisir
la verrière guyancourt les
clayes-sous-bois maurepas elancourt
magny les hameaux montigny le bretonneux
villepreux et enfin voisins le
bretonneux
alors ça ce sont les chiffres pour les
ordures ménagères mais il existe bien
d'autres types de déchets qui doivent
être triés de manière bien particulière
pour être parfaitement recyclés et c'est
comme moi vous avez un petit peu de mal
à vous y retrouver dans les couleurs
dans les poubelles
ce qui se recycle ou non eh bien écoutez
ceux qui suivent dans votre immeuble ou
dans votre pavillon vous disposez
généralement de deux à quatre poubelles
différentes
pas toujours facile de savoir à quoi
chacune correspond en général la verte
et pour le vert tout type de verre du
moment qu'il est propre et que vous ne
jetez pas les bouchons avec la jaune est
destiné aux plastiques
mais attention pas tous les types de
plastique les bouteilles bidons boîtes
métalliques aérosols cartonnettes et
briques de jus de fruits oui mais
surtout pas de polystyrène de filmer sac
plastique ou encore d'emballages soudés
comme des des autos des boîtes de pizza
contenant des restes
vous pouvez également y jeter vos
magazines prospectus revues et journaux
sauf évidemment si vous disposez d'une
poubelle bleue normalement destinés à ce
type de déchets
souvent des notices sont affichés à
proximité des poubelles ou même
carrément sur les poubelles
si vous avez le moindre doute jetez
votre déchets dans la poubelle classique
la poubelle ordures ménagères comme nous
le verrons un peu plus tard il sera quoi
qu'il en soit valorisé mais qui se
charge de collecter ces tonnes de
déchets ce sont des entreprises privées
avec lesquels la communauté
d'agglomération négocié des contrats de
prestations si tu as le sd nicollin et
c'est pure créé en 1965 c'est pure
compte 2500 collaborateurs et 1000
véhicules de collecte et de nettoiement
celle agences historiques de la société
acti verbal grignon qui est aujourd'hui
le principal prestataire en charge des
déchets sur saint quentin en yvelines
seules deux communes ou comporte la côte
et d'agglo vin blanc aujourd'hui 11 en
gestion avec différentes activités ou
propreté urbaine ou collecte ou
déchetteries ou les trois en effet ni
croyant historiquement avec c'est connu
depuis très longtemps nous avions
jusqu'à présent aux clients je souhaite
recruter deux tableaux on a aujourd'hui
plus qu'un qui représente deux communes
227 mille habitants
ça devient mécaniquement le des plus
gros clients des agences aujourd'hui
évidemment l'idée d'avoir un seul
interlocuteur nous permet d'être être
plus efficace sur l'ensemble des
demandes les rassembler avoir une vision
plus transversale de l'ensemble des
communes la société est résolument
tourné vers l'innovation
elle met à la disposition de ses
salariés une vingtaine de véhicules
légers électriques sur mon repas la
collecte se fait avec des camions
roulant au gaz plus écologique et moins
bruyant en concertation avec saint
quentin en yvelines
d'autres équipements innovants
pourraient être prochainement testé
notamment des bennes équipé de bras
robotisés ou bien une application gps
destiné aux usagers afin qu'ils puissent
éviter les voies empruntées par les
éboueurs toof le confondues c'est pure
récolte 70 mille tonnes de déchets par
an sur saint quentin en yvelines
un chiffre colossal toute la semaine des
dizaines de camions partent de lagence
de thiverval grignon à côté d'eux
plaisir pour venir collecter les déchets
de la communauté d'agglomération en
déchetterie ou en porte-à-porte les
employés peuvent démarrer à 5 heures du
matin ils travaillent par équipe de 2 ou
3 chaque équipe couvre un périmètre bien
précis qu'elle connaît en général
parker
pour savoir quand sortir vos ordures
rendez vous sur le site de saint quentin
en yvelines et cliquer sur l'onglet
l'agglo à votre service une fois
collectés les déchets sont ensuite
amenés à lagence de tigre vannes grignon
pour être triées et si possible
valoriser dans le tournant on va
ressortir le bois les papiers et les
cartons la ferraille
ce qui n'est pas valorisables partira en
déchets ultimes soit l'enfouissement ou
l'incinération le papier le carton vont
râler dans les cartonneries les
papeteries pour refaire la matière
première la ferraille va partir chez un
ferrailleur qui lui va la faire fondre
refaire métal et les terres et gravats
on va les sortir aussi pour s'en servir
pour faire mieux remblai quant aux
déchets dangereux pots de peinture
aérosol déchets souillés
ils seront incinérés dans un autre
centre classe est équipé d'un système
permettant de filtrer les fumées
toxiques
les déchets électroniques sont également
regroupés à thiverval mais partent
ensuite vers un centre de démantèlement
afin d'en valoriser les différents
matériaux et surtout éviter de renverser
les polluants dans l'environnement
enfin les déchets verts sont transformés
en compost qui viendra enrichir les sols
agricoles
et puisqu'on en est à parler des
prestataires de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines j'en profite
pour vous rappeler que là aussi la
gestion intercommunale des déchets
devrait permettre de faire des économies
d'une façon évidente comme dans tout
dans tout métier pardon ou dans toute
industrie
vous savez le poids du volume que vous
représentez est important auprès des
prestataires ou auprès des fournisseurs
il est clair que quand nous arrivons à
250 milles avec un marché qui est
important voire très important
les prestataires ont plutôt tendance à
vous écouter d'une oreille plus
attentive nous l'avons vu certains
déchets nécessite un traitement
spécifique je pense notamment au bois au
carton aux déchets électroniques et bien
pour tout cela la communauté
d'agglomération gère cette déchetterie
qui à terme après harmonisation devrait
proposer le même type de service avant
de partir à la découverte de l'une
d'entre elles il y a un chiffre à
retenir dix sept mille cinq cents tonnes
c'est la quantité de déchets collectés
les sept déchetteries du territoire en
pour comprendre comment elle fonctionne
je suis allé à la rencontre de pierre
dormieu de chez sita la société qui gère
la déchetterie de guyancourt citons
déchetterie qui appartient à la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la déchetterie
va vous permettre de vous débarrasser
des déchets de production irrégulière
donc ça va aller
depuis des déchets dangereux des pneus
éventuellement jusqu'au déchets de tonte
de pelouse
si vous êtes un particulier vous accédez
à la déchetterie gratuitement vous devez
vous munir de votre pièce d'identité et
d'un justificatif de domicile de moins
de trois mois
vous pouvez aussi demander à la
communauté d'agglomération un badge
d'accès en déchetterie qui facilitera
votre accès qui facilitera aussi le
suivi de vos visites
si vous êtes un professionnel vous devez
auparavant contactez l'agglomération
pour votre ville et lui payer des frais
correspondant aux frais d'enlèvement et
de traitement des déchets que vous
pourrez venir déposer ici sur la
déchetterie guyancourt
le fonctionnement est simple et l'agent
d'accueil est là pour vous aider vous
guider sur le tri vous pouvez apporter
des déchets inertes gravats des déchets
verts du mobilier ancien des équipements
électriques électroniques en fin de vie
des déchets dangereux comme vieux pots
de peinture ce que vous n'avez pas le
droit d'apporter c'est l'amiante
les produits radioactifs les ordures
ménagères quelques exemples si vous
amenez une porte en bois
le fait qu'il y ait quelques férus
raccrocher à la porte
les gonds et puis la poignée c'est pas
important ça valait dans le bois
si vous casser un mur chez vous s'il n'y
a pas de plâtre dans le tas de gravats
ça pourra aller dans la benne inerte à 6
lits à du plâtre à dans ce tas de
gravats ça ne pourra pas aller dans la
benne inerte ça devrait aller dans la
benne tout venant pourquoi les inertes
les vrais inerte
on va s'en servir pour remblayer des
carrières vous savez que ce sol de l'île
de france il est truffé de trous et donc
on remblai des carrières ça permet de
construire dessus
si vous nous amenez du plâtre à
l'intérieur lorsqu'il ya de l'eau qui va
couler au travers du terrain ça va à
nouveau faire des trous parce que le
plâtre va se dit
un point important pour nous c'est la
sécurité sur la déchetterie il peut y
avoir beaucoup de véhicules qui
manoeuvrent en même temps soyez
attentifs me sortez de votre voiture qu
au moment où c'est vraiment nécessaire
de le faire si vous venez avec des
enfants c'est mieux qu'il reste à
l'intérieur
attention notamment au roman poker-club
vous en savez désormais un peu plus sur
la manière dont sont gérés les déchets
sur saint quentin en yvelines
comme vous avez pu le voir il s'agit
d'une question primordiale qui nécessite
une logistique importante mais aussi un
peu de bonne volonté de la part de
chacun d'entre nous vous savez les
déchets c'est la sphère de tous chacun
prend sa part dans cette
dans cette réduction des coûts dans
cette valorisation
chacun doit y prendre sa part les
habitudes doivent
et seront amenés à charge et
progressivement pour le bien de tous
encore une fois